machine learning is awesome except when
it forces you to do advanced math the
tools for machine learning have gotten
dramatically better and training your
own model has never been easier we'll
utilize our understanding of our data
set rather than an understanding of the
raw mathematics to build a model that
gets us insights welcome to cloud a AI
adventures my name is Yu Feng Guo on
this show we'll explore the art science
and tools of machine learning while
machine learning might be a great
conversation topic at dinner parties
it's even more useful with code in this
episode we're going to train a simple
classifier using only a handful lines of
code in fact here's all the code that
we'll look at today to train our
classifier will use tensorflow
Google's open source machine learning
library tensorflow has a pretty large
API surface but the part we care about
today is just the high-level API is
called estimators estimators package up
the training loop for us so that we can
train a model by configuring it rather
than coding it by hand this takes away
much of the boilerplate allowing us to
think at a higher level of abstraction
and this means we'll get to play with
the interesting parts of machine
learning and not get too bogged down in
the details since we've only covered
linear models so far in this series
we'll stick with that here and revisit
this example in the future to extend its
capabilities so with that let's dive
right in and go to our Jupiter notebook
ok so here we are in our Jupiter
notebook and the first thing that we'll
do is import tensorflow as TF and numpy
as MP I like to print out the version
number of tensorflow to confirm which
version I'm using this week we'll be
building a model to distinguish between
three different types of very similar
flowers I realized that this may be less
interesting than the beer and wine from
the previous episode but these flowers
are a bit more difficult to distinguish
making this a more interesting challenge
in particular we'll be classifying
different species of iris flowers now
I'm not sure I could pick out an iris
flower from a field of roses but our
model is aiming to distinguish iris set
soda iris versicolor and iris virginica
we have a data set of members
of the height and width of these flowers
as petals and sepals these four columns
will serve as our features so let's load
our dataset in using tensor flows load
CSV with header function the data or
features are presented as floating-point
numbers and the label for each row of
data or Target is recorded as an integer
zero one or two corresponding to our
three species of flowers
now I've printed out the results four of
our loading and we can see that we are
now able to access the training data and
the Associated labels or targets using
named attributes next we'll build the
model
to do this we'll first set up the
feature columns
feature columns define the types of data
coming into the model we are using a
four dimensional future column to
represent our features and calling them
flower features building our model using
estimators is super simple using TF
estimators that linear classifier we can
instantiate the model by passing in the
future columns we just created the
number of different outputs that the
model predicts in this case three and a
directory to store the models training
burgers and the output files this allows
tensorflow to pickup training later on
from where I left off if needed this
classifier object will keep track of
state for us and we are now almost ready
to move on to the training there is just
one final piece to connect our model to
the training data and that is the input
function the job of the input function
is to create the tensor flow operations
that generate data for the model so we
go from raw data to the input function
which passes that data that is then
mapped by the feature columns to go into
the model notice that we use the same
name for the features as we did in
defining the future column this is how
the data is associated now it's time to
run our training to train our model
we'll dress run classifier train with
the input function passed in as an
argument this is how we connect our data
set to the model the train function
handles the training loop and iterates
over the data set improving its
performance with each step and just like
that we've completed a thousand training
step
our data said is not huge so this
completed rather quickly now it's time
to evaluate our results we can do this
using the same classifier object from
before as it holds the trained state of
the model to determine how good our
model is we run classifier not evaluate
and pass in our test data set then we
can extract the accuracy from the
metrics that are returned 96.6%
okay let's pause here and review what
we've achieved so far the estimators API
has given us a nice workflow of getting
our raw data and passing it through an
input function setting up our feature
columns and model structure running our
training and finally running our
evaluation this easy-to-understand
framework allows us to think about our
data and its properties rather than the
underlying math which is a great place
to be today we looked at a very simple
version of tensor flows high-level API
using a canned estimator in future
episodes we'll look at how to augment
this model with more details use more
complex data and add even more advanced
features thanks for watching that
episode of cloud AI adventures you can
catch the whole series here and if you
have any thoughts and comments feel free
to leave them down below